[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a una semana en el
mundo el programa de France 24 en el que
con nuestros periodistas invitados
conversamos sobre algunos de los hechos
más destacados de la semana Este
programa es el espacio para que los
periodistas den su opinión Comenten sus
puntos de vista sobre los temas de la
actualidad mundial para conversar sobre
los temas que hemos seleccionado para el
programa de hoy hemos invitado a Inés
capdevila ella es periodista y
secretaria de redacción de la nación
también corresponsal del diario El Mundo
en Estados Unidos y en es Bienvenida al
programa y qué tal termina su semana
muy bien a la espera del partido entre
Argentina y y Países Bajos así con
bastante nervios también a la semana
muchísima expectativa en torno a los
resultados de hoy en el mundial de Qatar
2022 también nos acompaña para conversar
hoy en nuestro programa Luz Elena
Pereira periodista conduce el programa
tertulia política del medio sin línea MX
también es asesora en comunicaciones
política o comunicación política Luz
Elena Bienvenida al programa y cómo
termina usted su semana Hola qué tal Muy
buenas tardes noches creo ya para
ustedes o todavía no bien todo muy bien
muchas gracias feliz porque hay solecito
gusto en estar con ustedes Santiago
inglés
Bueno pues ustedes también nuestros
televidentes nos pueden acompañar con
todos sus opiniones y comentarios
también sus preguntas a través de las
redes sociales Recuerden que estamos en
arroba Franz 24 guión bajo ese arroba
santilogo que es nuestra etiqueta Perdón
es mi cuenta personal y nuestra etiqueta
es numeral una semana en el mundo f24
todo junto todo pegado para que nos
dejen sus comentarios esta semana ha
sido intensa para Perú en particular en
Suramérica a raíz de la destitución de
Pedro castillo y la llegada al poder de
Lina de Dina boluarte Todo comenzó con
la decisión Del entonces presidente
Pedro castillo de disolver El Congreso y
hacer una reorganización nacional que
incluía también una nueva constitución
del país horas después en una sesión
extraordinaria del Congreso el
mandatario fue vacado por incapacidad
moral permanente que sigue entonces para
Pedro Castillo que sigue para la
presidente interina Dina boluarte que
tiene el reto de cal al país y también
darle una ruta un Norte para poder salir
de esta crisis política comienzo
entonces preguntándole a Inés
perspectivas opiniones sobre lo que ha
sucedido en Perú y estábamos ya
acostumbrados a estos episodios a estos
capítulos constantes de Un espiral de
crisis en Perú pero este sin duda alguna
fue un remesón contundente que también
Da inicio a un nuevo capítulo Cuál es su
opinión Inés
claramente Santiago como dicen el país
inmodernable dio otro capítulo bastante
esperable poco sorprendente de
ingobernabilidad lo curioso de Perú sin
embargo es que parece ingobernable en
términos políticos pero en términos
económicos mantiene una estabilidad que
es digna de admiración en países vecinos
por ejemplo la Argentina ahora
esa inestabilidad política también
condiciona mucho el futuro a largo plazo
de toda la sociedad peruana sobre los
más desfavorecidos los más marginados
que por falta de políticas económicas
que vayan al fondo de la cuestión de la
pobreza de la marginación de la
informalidad Entonces eso hace que ese
esa ese pueblo peruano siga con una
enorme cantidad de reclamos
insatisfechos y eso a su vez se traslada
a las elecciones presentando un arco
político muy fragmentado que además
tiene un reflejo en el congreso Entonces
se configura un panorama muy complejo
Que hoy pese la Asunción de Dina
boluarte no parece haberse estabilizado
no parece que esa sea tampoco la salida
esta crisis que piensa Luz Elena
nosotros acá en la redacción nos ha
costado mucho hacer el análisis de lo
que pueda pasar en este país porque es
completamente impredecible un día el
congreso da un paso el presidente da
otro la sociedad da otro todo se
revierten en sus pasos es completamente
impredecible que va a pasar con este
país
Este creo que es muy difícil hacer una
lectura rápida pero como bien decía Inés
hace un momento este lo que vive Perú es
la demostración de un gobierno inestable
de condiciones socioeconómicas y
políticas inestables que no son cosa de
ahora hemos estado viendo esto desde
hace varios años seis sustituciones en
un plazo muy corto una situación interna
con muchas demandas sociales con crisis
que muestran también una situación de
Gran pobreza con un posicionamiento de
lo que llamamos las izquierdas creo que
lo que sí estamos viviendo y veremos de
manera
pues muy fuerte en los próximos días en
las próximas semanas es dificultades muy
reales impactantes para la construcción
de un gabinete impactantes para la
construcción de los liderazgos este
en una política de estado que ve
estabilidad social que de estabilidad
política y que permita a quien esté en
el poder cubriendo de manera interina
esperando los procesos para llamar a
elecciones
Pues que y que se puedan realmente
conjuntar fuerzas para conducir la
administración pública de Perú
Luz Elena continuó con usted para hacer
la ronda la inversa aquí no no como
periodista sino como ciudadana como
latinoamericana usted puede entender qué
fue lo que hizo el presidente hoy en día
expresidente Castillo también hemos
hecho todo tipo de análisis aquí entre
colegas pensando en que hay un complot
en que le salió como no era en que fue
un paso en falso fue un error de cálculo
lo tenía premeditado todo tipo de
hipótesis cuál cree que pudo haber sido
Cuál es la suya Cuál es su idea y creo
que coincidimos en la dificultad para
hacer una para para mostrar o para decir
alguna hipótesis
yo lo primero que creí es que se había
anticipado y que le había fallado la
jugada pero también puede ser una
propuesta una una puesta mediática y que
quisiéramos ver cómo le va y esto tiene
que ver con las manifestaciones de
algunos representantes de estados
aquellos que les están llamando de
izquierda Uno de ellos es el presidente
de la República en México por ejemplo
hizo un llamado a la defensa Al cuidado
de sus derechos este humanos
[Música]
si bien no abiertamente vio una postura
si habló de la no intervención Y sí
habló bueno como en muchas otras
ocasiones este el mandatario mexicano
hace
lanza una mirada y por supuesto hace un
posicionamiento hacia la protección de
los intereses de quien en este momento
ha decidido parece dar un auto golpe de
estado que yo tengo dudas al respecto Sí
incluso el presidente mexicano lo han
criticado injerencia en este caso de
estar opinando mucho de un tema que en
el que no debería estarse metiendo
diferentes sectores en México lo han
criticado regreso con Inés para
preguntarle cuál es su hipótesis que
cree usted qué fue lo que pasó allí en
en Perú con el presidente ex presidente
Castillo
Bueno yo creo que intervinieron en el
autogolpe de Castillo mucho de los
factores que vos enumeraste hace unos
minutos primero un error de cálculo
segundo probablemente Castillo construyó
algunos apoyos para para hacer esta
jugada del autogolpe que cerrar el
congreso reorganizar el poder judicial y
esos apoyos al ver que no había un
contexto de aval generalizado y social a
la medida de castillos se retiraron sin
inmediatamente ahora a mí lo que no me
sorprende es
tenemos toda la torpeza con la que
generó todo el autogolpe Por qué Porque
Castillo a lo largo de 16 meses de
gobierno asumió A fines de julio del
mostró una serie
gigantesca de errores No forzados de
bastante incompetencia fue el manto que
cubrió su gobierno por lo tanto a mí no
me sorprende que haya sido este
autogolpe tan efímero
porque fue o mal planificado O hubo
apoyos que se retiraron o el propio
Castillo no supo leer la situación
puede ser esa también una de las
hipótesis claramente mostraba era una
muestra más de esta inexperiencia que
tenía en cuanto a la gobernabilidad y al
funcionamiento del Estado así también lo
han dicho algunos analistas Inés
pregunta rápida respuesta rápida para
pasar a hablar de la nueva presidenta de
los peruanos Castillo irá a México sí o
no
asilado
no lo creo por ahora le queda una semana
de de prisión preventiva y Bueno hay que
ver qué dice la justicia después irá a
prisión sí o no
bueno eso lo dirá la justicia peruana
pero a juzgar por los antecedentes de
otros presidentes es muy factible Luz
Elena También la misma pregunta ir a
México asilado sí o no sería que no
creería que no que se hizo la invitación
previa este al llamado golpe de estado y
no no creo
de hecho ya se hicieron este
declaraciones diciendo que la invitación
fue previo a la situación que se vivió
allá y lo ve usted en la cárcel sí o no
[Música]
No lo sé No lo sé Me parece que me
parece que es que es una cuestión de
política interna que que todavía no
podemos este tener elementos para dar
una respuesta a ese tipo de preguntas
este Santiago creo
hablemos de la otra protagonista de esta
historia y es la presidenta actual de
los peruanos una mujer lidera ahora este
país suramericano Dina boluarte asumió
el poder después de estas horas
convulsas allí en Perú les pregunto a
ustedes como mujeres como periodistas
que representa que una mujer llegue en
el 2022 apenas a gobernar Perú le
preguntó a Inés para hacer la ronda a la
inversa entonces
bueno claramente es un gran paso para
digamos las dirigencias femeninas de
América Latina que están tan digamos en
la retaguardia Sin embargo tal vez no
fue la mejor forma de que una mujer
accediera por primera vez al poder
peruano dicho esto tiene enormes
desafíos por delante de una boluarte Y
muchísimas chances de terminar con la
misma ingobernabilidad con la que
terminó Castillo Por qué Porque hay el
factor central de la política peruana No
no va a distinguir si es un presidente
hombre o es un presidente mujer que es
el Congreso y ese congreso muy
fragmentado también va probablemente
boicotear las medidas de boluarte y Luz
Elena su opinión
Este creo que
coincido con Inés de que llegue a
evaluarte al poder no es que llegue
volarte poderes que ha sido una decisión
en un contexto específico
Ojalá y tengamos más mujeres ocupando
puestos de dirección porque significaría
por supuesto un asunto de equidad de
justicia y de dignidad hacia las mujeres
un sector que ha estado relegado este
esperemos veamos en el futuro Cuáles son
los pasos que sigue pero creo que será
muy poco tiempo que habrá decisiones que
no le van a favorecer en términos este
de ese contexto político verdaderamente
fuerte que está viviendo Perú
bueno otra pregunta del millón que tengo
para ustedes y aquí también les pido que
se quiten un poco sus sus cargas como
periodistas y lo hablen desde lo más
profundo de su análisis personal y es si
ustedes ven que boluarte va a terminar
hasta el 2026 va a lograr culminar este
mandato que estaba previsto para el
expresidente Castillo eso hablaría bien
eso indicaría que podría estabilizar el
país en cierta forma si logra llegar
Entonces hasta hasta el término del
mandato cómo lo ve usted Inés
yo lo veo muy difícil primero cuando
asumió el miércoles Volverte dijo que
ella gobernaría hasta 2026 porque ese es
la fecha en la que se vence este mandato
sin embargo Ya esta mañana empezó a
decir que bueno que iba un poco a
analizar la posibilidad de convocar a
elecciones anticipadas entonces ahí ya
la presión política de ciertos sectores
para digamos legitimar un mandato
diferente se le hace sentir a Volverte
apenas dos días después de asumida
entonces a mí me cuesta muchísimo creer
y también acá insisto los antecedentes
de la historia reciente de Perú muestran
que es muy difícil para cualquier
mandatario en este arco tan fragmentado
de la política pero peruana terminar un
mandato es muy difícil Luz Elena
coincido totalmente creo que
independientemente de de la situación de
la condición de género el contexto
peruano no habla de la posibilidad de un
periodo largo para boluarte creo yo este
ya lo dijo creo que así será va a
convocar elecciones Y dónde queda el
congreso entonces Luz Elena un congreso
completamente
desprestigiado ante la ciudadanía
goza de cero credibilidad muy bajos
índices de popularidad entre los
peruanos Este es el meollo del asunto es
el meollo de esta crisis peruana que
análisis hace usted no yo creo que los
intereses económicos en la región
mundial y en la región hablan de una
gran imposibilidad para operar
liderazgos en en Perú como en otros
países que les va a ser muy muy difícil
al estado en su conjunto lograr la
gestión y la administración pública con
liderazgos sólidos porque las
condiciones este internas
y las intervenciones externas dificultan
la operación de liderazgos
precisos de Perú Sí y para el cierre de
este tema Inés escalemos un poco a la
región esto Cómo afecta América Latina a
nivel político una una región que ha
estado moviéndose un poco hacia la
izquierda con las últimas elecciones que
hemos visto a lo largo de este año ha
dado un giro pero pero esto deja mal
parada a la izquierda peruana deja mal
para esa izquierda latinoamericana y
esto como impactan la región
yo creo que no O sea no lo deja tan mal
parada por supuesto que es un golpazo
para para la izquierda peruana y algo un
poquito menos para la izquierda regional
que por qué Porque son diferentes tipos
de liderazgos dentro de la izquierda por
supuesto comparten una ideología presa
ideología también tiene como un espectro
diferente no es lo mismo boric que López
Obrador no es lo mismo Alberto Fernández
que el propio Lula pero hay algo que sí
yo creo que le resta legitimidad y es la
reacción de la izquierda latinoamericana
al autogolpe perpetrado por Castillo
hubo un autogolpe o sea Castillo lo
anunció los peruanos le dijo voy a
cerrar el congreso voy a reorganizar la
justicia y todo va a ser controlado por
las fuerzas armadas es el manual de
autogolpe la izquierda regional en los
ámbitos formales como la oea reaccionó
muy ambiguamente y yo creo que eso a los
ojos de las sociedades latinoamericanas
que están tan hartas las divisiones
políticas y tan necesitadas de un
crecimiento económico
fuerte y robusto eso le quita
legitimidad a los gobiernos de izquierda
Pues con esa reflexión de Inés nuestra
invitada vamos cerrando Este primer tema
que tenemos para el programa de hoy
vamos a hablar justamente de Argentina
porque también fue noticia esta semana
también hubo remezón político allí
Cristina Fernández de kirchner fue
sentenciada a seis años de prisión y fue
inhabilitada Para ocupar cargos públicos
en ese país Fernández es tal vez una de
las figuras más relevantes de la
historia reciente de la política
Argentina ha sido dos veces presidenta
esposa de un presidente que estuvo en el
poder durante dos periodos consecutivos
allí en la casa rosada Y actualmente es
vicepresidenta de Argentina la justicia
la acusa de fraude agravado y de liderar
asociación ilícita relacionada con
diferentes proyectos de infraestructura
en el sur de el país comienzo
preguntando la Inés Por supuesto que
está ahí nos puede contar cómo se
vivieron esos momentos porque si hay una
sociedad polarizada y dividida en torno
a la figura de Cristina Fernández Es la
sociedad Argentina y entorno a a
izquierdas y derechas es la sociedad
Argentina Inés su opinión sus
impresiones
bueno por
supuesto tensionó muchísimo a la
Argentina un poco más sobre todo
magnificó la grieta que nos gobierna
desde hace 20 años dicho esto también
con eso fue digamos en el día también
este fallo condicionaba mucho el futuro
político de la Argentina porque en
función de ello también Cristina va a
decidir Su futuro político y participa o
no de las elecciones de 2023 las
elecciones presidenciales de 2023 y de
participar es un escenario político de
no participar Cristina que sigue siendo
la figura central de la Argentina
también es otro escenario político por
lo tanto es la atención del martes se va
a proyectar hacia todo lo que de dos y
2023 de Cara a esas elecciones
presidenciales que que también se vienen
en ese país empieza esa atención
en torno a las elecciones Luz Elena su
opinión sobre este caso esta figura de
Cristina Fernández
arraigada ya en la política Argentina
muchos ya están cansados de verla a ella
en la figuración política Argentina
otros la ven como esa gran salvadora del
país que necesita Volver al poder o que
se tiene que mantener en algún cargo de
poder para seguir con su proyecto
y Bueno creo que
Cristina Fernández es un personaje que
tiene una trayectoria muy larga que es
una mujer que se ha mantenido en la
cúpula del poder político de un país por
muchos años a diferencias de lo que
decíamos hace unos momentos con respecto
a boluarte las dificultades que
enfrentan Unas y otras son distintas y
me parece que la situación de Cristina
Fernández es una situación muy destacada
muy destacada y también muy cuestionada
como bien Se ha dicho que está envuelta
en una crisis política muy muy grande
pero que también
responde
creería yo la situación que está
viviendo a la imposición de una
oligarquía de una oligarquía de una
clase política que no tiene escrúpulos
que se impone que impone sus intereses a
cualquier costo y que lo hemos visto No
solo en Argentina ahora lo hemos visto
en otros momentos en ese mismo país y lo
hemos visto en otros espacios como la
oligarquía se posiciona y este para todo
aquello que representa una una amenaza
para sus intereses Inés qué pensar de lo
que resta de esta causa que continúa
este proceso a nivel judicial allá en
Argentina hay garantías para
para creer en la división de poderes
allá en Argentina y garantías para este
proceso para garantizar un debido
proceso para la vicepresidenta y también
para garantizar a los argentinos que de
verdad la justicia está actuando como
debe ser
en El Paso de Cristina hay como una
digamos sensación generalizada en
Argentina Por supuesto que excluimos ahí
al kirchnerismo al digamos el bastión
electoral de Cristina que es un 23% de
la Argentina hay una sensación
generalizada de que este fallo cumple
con las generales de la ley y la
justicia falló de forma transparente
dicho esto sobre este fallo también Es
cierto que el poder judicial como el
congreso El Perú está completamente
manchado deslegitimado pero también
nosotros actores de este fallo Cristina
es un es probablemente la es la
dirigenta con mayor tasa de rechazo en
la Argentina Entonces es la
contraposición de actores políticos
incluida la justicia que están todos
manchados básicamente lo que esto hace
es quitarle credibilidad a las
instituciones en Argentina
pues vamos a ver qué va a qué rumbo va a
tomar esto en en Argentina en Luz Elena
esto qué tanto impacto puede tener en
esos comicios presidenciales que se
avecinan en ese país suramericano
teniendo toda esta atención presente es
parte de la estrategia también del
kirchnerismo cómo lo ve usted porque
aquí todo puede ser sacado a favor No
sí Y es interesante ver como en cada uno
de nuestros espacios tenemos distintas
religiones distintas visiones bueno que
en las que estamos obligadas a mirar
este las distintas aristas y a mí me
parece que la la bueno la la
este personaje
Cristina Fernández Ya dijo que no
participará
por lo que dice Inés Pues es de poco
creíble que no participen las elecciones
ella dice que no se presentará pero lo
cierto Es que entrará en un proceso
judicial de muy largo plazo y vamos a
ver que este cómo se mueve jurídicamente
hay de un Por una parte diciendo que
hubo una
legalidad
muy cuestionable en este proceso en el
en la que la sentencian a seis años y
por supuesto la inhabilitan creo que que
sí puede minar su participación pero
también le puede favorecer porque es una
mujer que maneja muy bien los espacios
mediáticos es muy buena para comunicar
lo que quiere comunicar pues ya lo
veremos qué decir de la justicia
Argentina y también que deciden los
argentinos sobre el futuro de su país y
si
le dan un cambio un giro político a esta
nación suramericana ya veremos Cuál es
el rumbo que va a tomar Argentina será
sin duda alguna un tema que estaremos
tratando a lo largo del 2023 sigo
avanzando con más temas destacados de
esta semana la revista Time presentó sus
habituales portadas de las
personalidades del año y el Héroe del
año ya es una tradición de larga Data
para esta publicación estadounidense el
presidente de Ucrania Bolo fue elegido
como el personaje del año por su
resistencia a la invasión de las tropas
rusas al territorio de su país y también
por lograr unir al pueblo ucraniano para
hacer frente a esta guerra una
estrategia que también les llevó a
recibir muchísimo apoyo a nivel
internacional entre tanto el Héroe del
año fue elegido un colectivo se trata de
las mujeres iraníes que salieron a las
calles para reivindicar sus derechos sus
libertades y sobre todo para rechazar la
muerte de la joven Masha a mini que ha
causado todo un revuelo de una serie de
manifestaciones
muy controvertidas que han llamado
muchísimo la atención de la comunidad
internacional allá en Irán Y por
supuesto pues ha puesto a reflexionar a
el gobierno de los ayatolas sobre la
conexión que tienen ellos con el pueblo
y las necesidades actuales del pueblo
iraní que pueden ser muy distintas a las
que necesitaban en la época del inicio
de la Revolución comienzo con Inés
preguntándole por estas estas dos
portadas
controvertidas para algunas personas
piensan que que el personaje del año
debió haber sido el presidente Putin por
la amenaza que representa para la
humanidad no estuvo al borde de una
hambruna por la crisis de los cereales
tiene a Europa en una crisis energética
y y pues tiene el mundo en vilo de lo
que pueda suceder en Ucrania era la
portada adecuada cómo lo ve usted
Bueno
por lo general también a la decisión de
quién es el o la persona del año siempre
le agrega un manto de un condimento
moral por lo tanto lo eliges elensky y
no a Putin porque Putin digamos su
invasión de Ucrania también condiciona
el bienestar de muchos otros millones de
personas más allá de las fronteras de
Ucrania por lo tanto aquel que defiende
el país y desciende la invasión
moralmente para la revista Time tiene
mayor valor yo creo que donde es
indiscutible es
la elección de las mujeres iraníes ahí
es y por varias razones primero porque
la voluntad de decidir sobre su propio
cuerpo en América Latina de la lucha por
la legalización del aborto es un poco un
correlato las mujeres quieren decidir
sobre su propio cuerpo bueno miran las
mujeres quieren decir sobre qué se ponen
y que no se ponen eso por un lado y por
el otro lado la valentía de salir las
calles y manifestarse en uno de los
países que tiene el mayor aparato de
represión pública y social del mundo
Entonces creo que es más merecido que
esas heroínas de Time es muy difícil de
encontrar y es muy diciente para
entender lo que está sucediendo en la
sociedad iraní en este momento en el
2022 en la instancia en la que estamos
después de una pandemia y y en una
sociedad que está haciendo frente a
múltiples factores externos las
sanciones internacionales la presión que
hay sobre el gobierno es un cóctel
bastante complicado de lo que se gesta
dentro de Irán es Luz Elena su opinión
sobre estas portadas y bueno en el caso
de la portada de
del presidente el presidente de Ucrania
Este creo que que Times es muy clara sus
portadas no definen una postura este son
una postura política este en ella se
reconoce se afirma
[Música]
los órdenes sociales tiene claramente
una postura política este Putin Ya
apareció en una portada y aparece con un
bigotito de Hitler
[Música]
el personaje que aparece en su portada
Me parece que dice muchas cosas la
vestimenta que trae este el manejo de
los medios y me parece que también un
acuerdo para este Mostrar algo que se
quiere mostrar en la portada y Bueno
pues hablamos de diferencias muy
concretas que han sido apoyados por unos
y por otros no Pero es una a mí me
parece una portada disruptiva en el caso
de la portada de las mujeres de Irán Las
heroínas del año este que luchan por su
libertad
decían que luchan por poder decidir que
ponerse me parece que es una un llamado
este
el reconocimiento
a mujeres que no solo están luchando por
que ponerse no por tener permisos si no
están luchando por su vida este por ser
por poder posicionarse dignamente en el
mundo Luz Elena Qué opinión tiene usted
Qué opinión tengo de ese personaje me
parece que es un personaje que ha
logrado posicionar una lucha interna de
su país
utilizando muy bien los medios de
comunicación creo que puede hasta
sentirse gozoso por ejemplo de algunos
alcances que ha tenido a través de la de
una postura mediática y me parece además
que es un hombre valiente
Inés su opinión sobre esta figura por lo
de miel zelanski lo que ha representado
Qué opinión tiene de él yo en particular
personalmente a mí me llama muchísimo la
atención la metamorfosis de selensky no
era un presidente muy popular hasta el
24 de febrero de
de este año con el día de la invasión
rusa y ahora se transformó
verdaderamente en probar el presidente
más importante de Europa entonces creo
que a mí esa esa metamorfosis me llama
mucho la atención Bueno pues vamos
llegando al final del programa Quiero
preguntarle a inesia Luz Elena
rápidamente y muy puntual a Qué temas
les van a estar poniendo la lupa van a
estar prestando la atención la próxima
semana en sus diferentes medios en sus
análisis en sus columnas en sus en los
programas para los que trabajan comienzo
con Inés para hacer la ronda la inversa
adelante
Bueno o sea Santiago como hablábamos
recién lo más importante en la Argentina
hoy es primero el mundial y segundo el
futuro de Cristina kiyonara Así que
probablemente todo nuestra digamos
nuestra cobertura de tenorientadas las
que ahí y obviamente Perú y se les
aclaró un poco el panorama Brasil ya
quedó por fuera de Qatar 2022 y se le
despeja un poco el panorama Argentina
Luz Elena adelante
bueno nosotros vamos a estar trabajando
por supuesto en el en el cierre de las
actividades en las cámaras altas y baja
alta y bajas
tenemos lo que fue el acuerdo para pasar
al senado de la República de la Reforma
electoral por supuesto vamos a seguir el
mundial nosotros lo hemos estado
siguiendo desde este lo que significa un
un gran negocio este nacional e
internacional Entonces este pues
esperamos que Argentina este
juegue y juegue bien este tenemos la
camiseta también puesta con Brasil y
también estaremos hablando de pues
muchísimas gracias Inés Luz Elena por
haber estado con nosotros es todo por
esta semana la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Keila maestra y la
producción de invitados estuvo a cargo
de Tania Herrera gracias por haber
estado con nosotros
[Música]